is it possible to push Hitler kind of
over that threshold from either male to
female or really upset his fragile
masculinity so how can we do this what
if we inject female sex hormones into
the vegetables that Hitler eats if he
eats these hormones then that's really
going to push him over the edge and his
mustache is going to fall out his voice
is going to turn soprano and his chest
is going to grow breasts this will
decimate his fragile ego and he's going
to lose all of his credibility and
people aren't going to take him
seriously and will somehow win the war
this is the idea
what do you do what's your job I'm a
historian I'm a professor at the
University of Texas but I also write
books you know this one that just came
out the dirty tricks Department that's
the book that I've been working on for a
year so I'm glad it is finally out there
for people to enjoy hopefully what is
the story of the dirty tricks Department
what is it how did it come about
yeah this this is the story of a group
of scientists during World War II who
created the secret weapons documents and
disguises for the OSS this is the
precursor to the CIA the office of
strategic Services I had come across
this topic when I was working on my
dissertation in grad school which was on
science in the intelligence community
and then I came across some of the
figures that appear in this book and so
my while my dissertation was on a
different topic I couldn't help myself
but really want to learn more about this
topic and so I was kind of doing a dual
uh investigation in the archives I had
to finish my dissertation but my heart
was interested in researching this stuff
so this is the product of that kind of
research that I just couldn't help
myself from doing on the OSS and its
dirty tricks Department what is the
Genesis of the dirty tricks Department
then does it grow out of the OSS is it
built and then tacked on how does that
work
yeah it's it kind of grows out of the
OSS for the most part
um so the OSS is in charge of uh
coordinating kind of intelligence during
World War II for the United States it
did things like sin spies abroad and
gather information and analyze that
information uh and spread disinformation
uh abroad one of the things that it also
does is uh create these weapons and
gadgets and disguises and forged
documents that I mentioned and that
became the job of the research and
development branch of the oss the r d
Branch or what I call the dirty tricks
department and so that pretty quickly
grew out of the OSS as the head of the
OSS William Donovan realized that he
needed scientists to create these things
so that the spies and saboteurs who are
being sent abroad are equipped and can
do their jobs
there is an equivalent that happened in
the UK and I'm pretty sure that uh
Churchill's Ministry of ungentleman the
Warfare uh is kind of is that does that
feel like a parallel does that feel like
the anglicized sister book to what you
wrote there are definitely parallels
between those two organizations so the
the kind of parallel to the OSS for the
British is the soe the Special
Operations executive I'll talk about
that a little bit in my book because the
OSS especially this r d branch that I
talk about and the soe are sharing a lot
of their ideas so there's a lot of
collaboration back and forth one of the
things they collaborate on are creating
specialized pills for these agents so
one of the pills the most well known is
like the L pill lethal pill a cyanide
pill another thing that the British work
on that doesn't really make it to the
OSS but they're doing independently that
I talk about a little bit because it's
almost too interesting not to include
was the idea of a rat bomb so the rat
bomb was
you would take a a dead rat Taxidermy it
you would kind of hollow it out and
stuff in explosives and you would throw
this rat into a coal reserve of say the
Germans the idea being that the Germans
would shovel the coal into their boilers
of their locomotives and they're not
going to stop to pick out rats if they
happen to shovel in a rat and they'll
just shovel in a rat well this this rat
bomb it's going to have explosives
inside of these rats they'll shovel it
into their boilers and it's going to
explode it's going to destroy their
trains so that was a British invention
the oss the r d Branch did something
very similar called black Joe which was
kind of hollowed out lumps of coal so it
wasn't a rat but the same idea you'd
hollow out these lumps of coal you'd
stuff explosives and throw it in the
cold reserve for the same effect
hopefully
how did the agents keep the L pill on
them at all times
so
for the L pill they would well there are
a few ways most of the time though they
would just keep it in a pocket or
something so I tell one story in the
book of William Donovan the head of this
OSS on the day after D-Day you know so
he's wanting to be in the action this is
kind of a common theme with William
Donovan he is dying to be in the action
he was a World War One war hero he had
earned the Medal of Honor during World
War One and he couldn't stand not being
in the action sitting behind the desk so
he decides he wants to get involved in
the Normandy invasion so on D-Day uh or
the day after he goes onto the beaches
and he goes up to where kind of the
German line is and he starts getting
shot at and he's with one of kind of his
right hand man
they're getting shot at they drop
beneath some bushes and they start
talking to one another and this David
Bruce his kind of colleague who's with
him asks Jonathan what are we gonna do
how are we going to get out of the you
know what's going to happen and Donovan
reaches in his pocket and he's rummaging
around and he's looking for his L pill
that he's been supplied with by this r d
Branch his cyanide pill because he
Figures it's better to kill ourselves
than to have the Germans capture us and
interrogate us and potentially get
information out of us he ends up not
being able to find his L pill he kind of
makes a joke that I hope the you know
the person who's cleaning my hotel
doesn't you know see these pills and
take them with them
um but David Bruce this guy he Donovan
tells Bruce well you know I don't have
the L pill so I think I'm just gonna
have to shoot first and Bruce doesn't
really understand what Donovan means he
assumes that oh you're gonna shoot first
at the Germans and you're going to
supply cover for us so that I can run
away and Donovan says no you've
misunderstood me I'm going to shoot your
first as your commanding officer you
first as your commanding officer it's my
Duty that way you don't have to do the
Dirty Work of killing me I'll kill you
then I'll kill myself but eventually
they were able to get away that didn't
happen but yeah so L pills could be
stashed anywhere but
um one of the ways was just in a pocket
another way is in that Stanley level the
main character of this book he comes up
with is to get hollowed out razors so
like a Gillette razor hollow out kind of
the inside and you can just stash pills
in there and it's going to be really
hard to look who's gonna think to look
in this hollowed out part of a razor so
there are a few kind of ingenious ways
that came up
William Donovan is essentially the head
of the precursor to the CIA
and decides that he wants to be in the
action storming the beaches of Normandy
the day after D-Day
that's right that's what that guy
decided to do okay that's psychotic okay
tell me about William Donovan who is
this man what sort of a person is he uh
what's his working protocols like yeah
so like I mentioned he was a World War
One war hero he was pretty much the most
decorated American uh kind of soldier in
World War one so a really high highly
decorated he was shot in the leg with a
machine gun while he was commanding his
troops
um and he he eventually got the Medal of
Honor he was a lawyer he had gone to
Columbia Law School around the same time
that FDR Franklin Roosevelt had when
Franklin Roosevelt had left the
governorship of New York Donovan ran to
be the governor of New York he lost that
but he had a close relationship with FDR
um they were of differing political
philosophies Donovan was a republican
fdro Democrat but they were still
relatively close during the 1930s before
World War II begins FDR sends Donovan to
Europe to kind of gauge the situation to
feel out what the tensions are between
countries Donovan comes back telling FDR
that he thinks it's inevitable that
another war is going to break out and he
urges Roosevelt to create some kind of
centralized intelligence organization
that will be able to gather information
and keep the president keep FDR as
up-to-date and informed as possible on
events that are happening abroad
John is there no there's no other
equivalent kind of agency or
organization to collect this sort of
information and give it to the president
before this well there there are these
agencies but they have some problems in
Donovan Donovan's view especially
associated with the military branches
there's like Army intelligence Naval
intelligence but Donovan is worried that
they're not coordinating their
information so the president you know he
he's getting a bunch of different views
another problem Donovan sees is that
they're duplicating research so we have
all these different organizations doing
the same thing whereas we're just
wasting money we should have a
centralized group that's able to
coordinate all of this and analyze it
for the president that way we can trust
what's being done
um so that That's the basis at least of
his view of what the OSS should do so he
eventually persuades Roosevelt to create
this organization what will become the
oss the office of strategic services and
he's appointed as its head so that's
kind of how Donovan ends up being the
head of this organization got you and
what is he like once he gets in the OSS
because it doesn't seem like his gung-ho
War fearing warmongering ways have been
left behind him not at all that the
gung-ho is a good term to describe
William Donovan the organization is kind
of a reflection of his own personality
too he is someone who flies by the by
the seat of his pants he doesn't want to
ask permission for anything he just
wants to do it and that's kind of
reflected in the organization itself
like I said the main character of this
book is this guy Stanley Lovell he's a
chemist who's put in charge of this r d
Branch Stanley level originally doesn't
quite know what his job is supposed to
be he's recruited by Donovan to create
all these weapons and disguises but
Donovan never tells him here's what you
need to create he just tells level well
do it create stuff that's useful for us
level doesn't know what to do so we
asked David Bruce that guy who had who
would accompany Donovan on Normandy he
asked him what do I do you're his right
hand man give me some advice and David
Bruce says don't ask what to do just do
something and then ask for forgiveness
if necessary but just do it you know so
that was kind of the guiding principle
fly by your seat of the pants throw
things against the wall see what sticks
and you know we'll try to get through
this there's something so
kind of almost romantic and Whimsical
and nostalgic about the fact that both
the UK are equivalent over here uh the
ministry of and gentlemanly warfare and
you guys with uh what you were doing
with this research group
are just trying stuff out aniseed balls
as timers for Limpet minds and making
foxes glow and trying to turn Hitler
trans all of which we'll we'll get on to
in a little bit
um so William Donovan he gets introduced
he gets told uh just do stuff make make
chaos and and create some useful tools
that are uh soldiers and our special
operators can use overseas
what does he start with what's the first
thing that he does well the main kind of
mission of the OSS again is to gather
intelligence so you first have to
recruit agents who are going to do that
for you and develop connections abroad
of people who know the geography know
the terrain are able to see what the
German troop movements are doing so
that's kind of the main thing for the
OSS but in doing that it quickly becomes
evident that you're going to need this r
d branch that supplies these agents how
are they going to get their disguises
well we need someone to create that
um so Roosevelt would frequently call
Donovan well Roosevelt kind of had he he
was paralyzed he couldn't walk and so he
called Donovan my secret legs this is
someone who's going to go out and find
stuff out for me and bring it back to me
so that's you know that's kind of the
purpose of the OSS right okay
they need to get some different agents
or I guess they would were they called
agents at the time
uh yeah so uh the recruits for the OSS
if you wanted to be a recruiter if you
were recruited you would have to go to a
training school so in Maryland at the
what's the Congressional Country Club
the OSS basically took this land over
during World War II it became known as
area F and area F was a place where all
of these recruits were trained in how to
engage in this unconventional warfare so
where where the driving range for golf
balls had previously existed it became a
rifle range where they would practice
their shooting the bunkers you know with
sand in them for for shots it became a
target practice for their mortars and
all kinds of stuff and on the
Congressional Country Club there's a
clubhouse in the basement floor of that
Clubhouse became what's known as the
Maryland research laboratory and this is
the laboratory where Stanley level and
his underlings tried to develop all of
these weapons right so Stanley is in
charge I'm gonna guess he was basically
not the was no oversight or very little
oversight from William Donovan is that
right correct yes Stanley level is this
New England chemist who gets recruited
to join the OSS when he's recruited he
actually is told to go to OSS
headquarters and he shows up kind of
after hours it's all dark no one's
really there and he gets tapped on the
shoulder by a security guard and he
spooked oh my gosh he didn't know anyone
was there and he's led to a room and
he's waiting in this room for a long
time not even knowing really what he's
doing there because he doesn't know much
about the OSS it's the secret
organization all of a sudden this giant
figure walks in the room he's got a
medal of honor lapel pin on him and he
says I want you to be my professor
Moriarty and it was William Donovan
saying this to Stanley level Professor
Moriarty being the kind of antagonist in
the Sherlock Holmes novels this is the
you know the bad guy but I want Donovan
tells him I want you to create all the
dirty tricks for this organization so
that's how Stanley level gets wrapped up
in all this he's initially yeah yeah
he's initially reluctant to to join
because he's a chemist and he wanted to
use his scientific expertise for good he
thought he had kind of an obligation to
do that but he realizes that he's also
growing up he was an orphan basically
both of his parents died very young he
was raised by his sister he got a great
education and he thought that he owed it
to his country to do something to help
in this war so one of the arcs of the
story is seeing levels internal tensions
he doesn't want to use his scientific
expertise to harm others but at the same
time he feels a debt that he owes to his
country that he feels he can repay by
joining this organization and creating
these weapons right
when does he make the exploding pens
when does that happen
um that's that's pretty early on there's
uh kind of just to break down the
hierarchy of this there's the OSS one of
the branches within the OSS is this r d
Branch the research and development
branch that Stanley level is in charge
of and then that's kind of broken into
three different divisions there's
division 19 which creates all the
weapons there's the documents division
which forges all the documents and then
there's the camouflage division which
creates all the disguises so division 19
is in charge of creating you know the
pen guns and the all you know the
exploding flower all that kind of stuff
the the incendiary devices bat bombs so
that's that one division that happens
pretty early
um after the r d branch is created okay
what in terms of document forgery that
seems like the least exciting
group to be a part of is that fair
you're just trying to create German
passports all day and stuff
um maybe if from a work perspective at
that time yeah maybe that would be the
least exciting from my perspective it's
one of the most exciting because looking
at the details of what they did is
incredible so it's really exciting to
begin what did they do
um so for a document you had to be so
specific that it it it really is
extremely impressive for instance if you
wanted to forge a German ration ticket
or a or anything a license or a passport
or anything not only did you have to
kind of use the right signatures and
Forge the right stamps to stamp on them
you also had to use the right kind of
like paper so you had to analyze what
kind of Pulp is being used in this paper
and it just gets so incredibly complex
and the idea that they figured this out
is really incredible one of the
interesting things about the documents
division two is that the characters
within it are really exciting themselves
some of the forgers that work for this
documents division were sprung from
prison because they had been forging
government bonds and money and all kinds
of stuff and they got caught and were
sent to prison it's a Stanley level
recruits them hey you've got this skill
we could use the you and the war you
know and maybe this will look favorably
upon your you know sentencing or
something like that so prisoners were
used in this documents division
especially people who were experts at
signatures who could force Forge the
signatures of all kinds of people one of
the most well-known
in this division was Jim the Penman his
real name is kind of never really
revealed but it was said that Jim the
pen Penman would get his colleagues to
sign their signature on a page and he
would recreate their signatures up and
down the page multiple times and he
would bet them five bucks that they
wouldn't be able to pick out their
original signature and he got you know a
lot of money off of this I thought he's
so good okay so the camouflage division
what do they create what are they
working on yeah they're in charge of the
disguises so they're in charge of
procuring the different kinds of
um anything that you might wear as an
undercover agent so one of the things
they did was try to get immigrants who
were coming to the United States
European immigrants they would offer to
buy their clothes off of them so they
could have authentic clothing for these
agents going abroad another interesting
thing they do is create secret
compartments within like clothing so
that you could
carry messages with you without a German
guard say if he were to Frisk you or
something wouldn't be able to detect it
so these secret message Chambers were
put into all kinds of things you could
hollow out the soul of your shoe you
could
um one of my favorite ones is involves
lipsticks for female agents so the idea
would be you would have a message you
would roll it up really small you would
melt the wax of lipstick and you would
put the message in the tube and then you
would pour the wax back into the tube
and like mold it to look like lipstick
so the lipstick would be surrounding the
message and you would never know because
it just looks like lipstick yeah so some
of the other things that the camouflage
division would do would artificially age
people so putting charcoal in the
wrinkles of the face would make the
wrinkles look deeper and make you look
older applying some white to the temples
of your you know your hair makes you
look a little bit older you could put
stuff newspaper into your shoe to kind
of throw off your gate and make you a
little bit taller there were all kinds
of these tricks of the trade rub your
hands on Rusty metal and then on your
face and it would give you a little bit
different complexion
wow okay so this is like you know we
look at Prosthetics and Hollywood and
cosmetic surgery and stuff now
this is the most Village backyard
equivalent of that done whatever 80
years ago yeah for the most part I I
think some of the simplest uh kind of
inventions and disguises tend to be the
most ingenious because it's just so
simple I just love the simple ones but
it actually gets it does get fairly
complicated there are agents who undergo
like facial reconstruction surgery no
they'll have their they'll have their
job broken to give their face a little
bit different look or they'll graft
there's one person that I talk about
um George langolin he was this agent for
for the British actually he gets trained
by American so American people but he
has from a young age he had a very
protruding ears very large ears that
were very distinctive and he spoke
French which made him very valuable
because he could go to France and train
these resistance forces but he knew a
lot of people in this region and they
were worried that he's going to be
noticed you know they're going to know
who he is and so he undergoes surgery to
change the shape of his chin but also to
kind of pin back his ears so they're a
little bit less distinctive
or he might have been happy about that I
don't know if he's been teased about his
ears all of the time okay
um what about psychedelics I know that
after the uh after World War II were
talking about MK Ultra we're talking
about the OSS and its involvements there
did they decide to try and dip their toe
in early during World War II with any
psychedelics
well one of the one of the things that
Stanley level wants to do is to develop
a truth drug for interrogations this has
been kind of the goal of intelligence
agencies for a long time if you can have
a truth drug you can give it to someone
you're interrogating and they have no
choice but to tell you the truth that's
the idea at least you know this has been
around for forever basically with
alcohol the idea that you can apply
someone with a few drinks it'll lower
their inhibitions they'll tell you the
truth during the 1920s there was
actually a doctor in Dallas Robert house
who thought that he had come across a
truth drug and this is later going to
really
um get the OSS interested in what he was
doing he had given a drug called
Scopolamine to a woman who was in labor
kind of a sedative and suddenly she
started talking and telling him all
kinds of stuff that he thought you
shouldn't be telling me this like this
is not stuff that normal people would
say and he starts realizing or he starts
thinking to himself that perhaps this
drug scopolamide had somehow dimmed her
creative capacities it had prevented her
from imagining things and if that was
true the only thing that she could say
was the truth she couldn't invent Any
Lies so maybe that's why she's saying
this stuff that turned out not really to
be the case but you know this is the the
kind of idea of this Cruise drug deal it
eliminates your capacities to invent
lies therefore the only thing that you
can say is the truth
this gets picked up during World War II
when Stanley level decides he wants to
test different substances to see if they
have this potential truth drug quality
one of the main one he catches on is
kind of concentrated THC like marijuana
you know this is the main psychoactive
ingredient in marijuana this actually
seems to work he does several
experiments with this he's giving it to
OSS personnel and literally recording
what they say and measure measuring how
much how many words they speak on the
THC they speak a lot more than off of it
now the problem is this doesn't
guarantee that what you're saying is the
truth it just means your inhibitions are
a little bit lowered but there were all
kinds of experiments with these truth
drugs one of the main people that
Stanley level hires to do these
experiments is a guy named George White
George White was an officer with a
bureau of Narcotics a Narcotics officer
officer his job is to clean drugs off
the street but now his job becomes
giving drugs to people with his true
these truth drug is experiments so he's
injecting THC into cigarettes and
handing it to his criminal contacts the
idea being if they start talking about
the crimes they've committed this is
probably a good indication that this
truth drug is working and so he does
this most famously to a gangster in New
York named August Del gracio and Del
gracio starts telling him about the
people he could have killed and the the
politicians who are taking bribes and
all kinds of stuff so George White
writes a report saying this stuff is
great you know this this truth drug is
really working
um so anyways one of the lasting
legacies of this r d branch that I talk
about is that these experiments are
going to really influence a lot of
experiments that take place in the CIA
especially this MK Ultra program
wasn't this something about a fear of
them putting LSD in the water or did
that come after World War II
um that's mostly afterwards during the
Cold War
um once the CIA is established kind of
the successor to the oss the main guy
who's put in charge of this MK Ultra
program which is kind of the U.S CIA
mind control program to figure out
whether mind control truth drugs all
that kind of stuff is possible either
through drugs or hypnosis or something
like that the guy who's in charge of
that is a chemist like Stanley Lovell
his name is Sydney Gottlieb and one of
the main motivations for trying to see
whether mind control is possible is the
fear that the Soviets are going to put
LSD into say a city's water supply and
if they do that Sydney Godley wants to
know how are people going to react you
know if how how are we going to detect
whether this is you know happening if
someone
puts LSD into our water supply are
people going to start killing each other
or how are they going to behave we need
to know this so that we can prepare for
it and so one of the motivations for
giving unwitting people LSD is to see
how they're affected by it without
knowing that they're getting it because
if the Soviets do that we need to know
you know how that how that's going to
turn out at least that's kind of the
rationale very interesting so going back
to injecting people with stuff what was
this mission to try and trans Hitler
yes so this is Stanley level in the r d
Branch there is an OSS a psychologist
who's working with the OSS who writes a
report on Hitler's personality trying to
understand who Hitler is maybe he has
vulnerabilities that can be exploited
one of the things that this psychologist
points out Henry Murray he writes this
report saying that Hitler has a large
feminine component to his personality is
what he says in the report you know he
says uh that he has kind of these sexual
is a masochist and all kinds of stuff is
submissive and Stanley level reads this
report and he he wants to figure out a
way to use this to the advantage of the
United States is it possible to push
Hitler kind of over that threshold from
either male to female or something like
uh really upset his fragile masculinity
so how can we do this Stanley level
comes up with the idea that what if we
inject female sex hormones into the
vegetables that Hitler eats if he eats
these hormones then that's really going
to push him over the edge and his
mustache is going to fall out his voice
is going to turn soprano and his chest
is going to grow breasts this will
decimate his fragile ego and he's going
to lose all of his credibility and
people aren't going to take him
seriously and will somehow win the war
this is the idea at least so Stanley
level in his Memoir he says that he got
some of these female sex hormones he was
able to give it to a gardener in Germany
who supplied the eagle's nest with its
vegetables where Hitler kind of
frequently went and so Stanley level
said yeah we got the sex hormones to
this person but we never knew really
what happened to it either the gardener
got cold feet or Hitler's tasters had a
there was a large turnover in them so
well you know I don't know what happened
to it but apparently it didn't go
through well I mean when you think about
Hitler's uh psychological physiological
Health throughout the war Theodore
morale that was his personal physician
is just I mean first off completely
insane in injecting him with bull semen
and speed and heroin and crack and
cocaine and absolutely everything by the
end of the war he's done like 10
injections a day I think
um but there is a lot going on like he's
got a lot to deal with it seems like
Hitler was pre-alco simic or something
similar maybe had like a parkinsonian
Tremor or something that was going on
it's a famous video is it when he's
meeting Mussolini and he's got one hand
behind his back and the hand that's
behind his back on the video won't stop
trembling I think which is pretty
interesting and um
yeah there was another a plot kind of
dealing with his ego one idea was that
this doesn't come from the r d Branch
but from some other kind of psychologist
he's pitching it to the Air Force the
the Army Air Force the idea being we
should drop pornography all over
Hitler's place where he's staying and he
doesn't like pornography and it's going
to upset him and so he's going to walk
out he's gonna see he's gonna see the
smut these naked women and he's gonna
it's gonna throw him into a rage and you
know he's going to lose this temperament
and somehow that's going to help he so
this psychologist actually got to a kind
of an Air Force General and was
explaining this plan and he was promptly
thrown out of the office and that didn't
go anywhere I never understood how that
would actually help the war but
apparently it was some kind of
psychological scheme that was cooked up
was there any other psychological
warfare tactics that they decided to try
and attempt yes several um I have a
chapter in in the book that talks just
about psychological warfare this is one
of the most interesting ones because
they really do get pretty outlandish one
uh this this one's fairly well known but
there's a substance called who me that
the r d branch of the OSS created who me
it's the sub substance that smells
really bad the idea was that we can hire
a chemical engineer to manufacture this
substance that smells like feces or
vomit or skunk or something like that
and we're gonna sneak the substance in
these tubes to little boys in Japan and
or little boys in China and the Japanese
are occupying China these little boys
are going to squirt the substance on the
back side of the Japanese officials and
it's going to embarrass them and they're
you know because it's going to smell
really bad and so they'll be demoralized
and maybe they'll you know make a bad
decision or something that was at least
the idea so it was called humi I don't
know if it had too much practical value
Stanley level does tell a funny story
where he kept this locked up in his
office in a kind of a cabinet with a
lock on it well of course pretty much
everyone in the OSS was taught how to
pick locks so some jokester
um decided to start pick the lock and
take some humi and was squirting around
the office level decided to set a booby
trap the next time this happened so he
booby trapped the lock so that whenever
anyone picked it and opened the cabinet
it would spray the humi back at them and
so level he says one night someone came
in picked the lock opened the cabinet
they got sprayed he never reveals who it
was but he says it was someone too
highly placed for me to discipline so I
you know it was someone apparently
pretty high up in the OSS wasn't there a
story of somebody going into the
president's office and unloading a full
clip of a gun behind him yeah yes
William Donovan himself the head of the
OSS he wanted to show Franklin Roosevelt
the kinds of things that his
organization was working on because it
never hurt to impress the president
you've got to have this guy on your side
so he wants to impress Roosevelt and so
how better to impress him than with a
silence flashless pistol so so Donovan
walks to Roosevelt's office and he he
was friendly with Roosevelt so he was
often just waved in so he's waved into
the office by the security guard he
drops a bag of sand in the corner of the
office meanwhile President Roosevelt is
dictating a letter to his secretary so
he's not really even looking at the door
he doesn't know Donovan has entered
Donovan pulls out this silenced
flashless 22 pistol that Stanley level
in the r d branch have created and he
unloads the clip into this bag of sand
in the office after a little while
Roosevelt smells burnt gunpowder and he
turns around and he sees Donovan
standing there with his empty pistol in
his hand and he's flabbergasted he
thinks this is a great you know I didn't
even realize this thing had gone off so
Donovan makes kind of a show of it he
hands the pistol to the president and
lets him keep it and Roosevelt kind of
jokes you're the only Republican I would
ever allow in my office with a gun
oh man it's so this is what I mean when
I say sort of whimsical and beautifully
nostalgic the fact that the the gloves
are off and the rules are out of the
window and no one's got any rules or
procedures everyone can just do what
they want
um
one of my favorite I don't know whether
you class this as psychological warfare
but operation Fantasia I think is my
favorite story from the entire book tell
people from the beginning what operation
Fantasia was yeah this might be my
favorite one too I was so excited I had
I had heard generally that this idea
existed the idea that we would somehow
use foxes to scare the Japanese and the
more I looked into this and the more
documents I found the more ridiculous I
realized and just really incredible and
insane this plot really was so this idea
of operation Fantasia was the brainchild
of a of a a businessman named ed
Salinger he had done a lot of business
before the war in Tokyo so he kind of
knew Japanese culture he knew the
Japanese language that's what made him
very valuable to the OSS because he kind
of knew the psychological profile they
thought of who the Japanese were and
they wanted to use that to exploit to
demoralize the Japanese so he's hired Ed
Salinger by the OSS he's part of What's
called the morale Opera
which was in charge of spreading
disinformation but he gets the r d
Branch to help on this project the idea
with operation Fantasia
kind of goes back to uh an ideal within
Shinto religion that there exists these
portents of Doom called kitsuni kitsuni
are like Spirit beings animal glowing
animal beings that if you see one it's
supposed to be a bad Omen something bad
is going to happen Salinger wants to
capitalize on this by creating kind of
fake kitsuni fake Spirit beings and if
we can release them in Japan it'll make
the Japanese scared and think that
something bad is going to happen well
what bad is going to happen well we're
in a war it probably means we're going
to lose this war we might as well give
up now then wait for that end to come in
some even worse way that's the idea at
least and so Ed Salinger has a few ideas
for how to capitalize on this
he wants to create either glowing Foxes
or the idea that there are glowing foxes
to scare the Japanese and so one is one
idea is to create a whistle that mimics
a fox sound we'll spread these
throughout Japan people start blowing
these whistles they're gonna think it's
the kitsuni because it's foxes and
they'll be demoralized you know this
didn't really go anywhere because do
people really know what foxes sound like
you know it sounds like yeah precisely
yeah yeah like that YouTube video what
does the fox say what does the fox sound
like is good enough yeah exactly yeah so
that was that didn't go
um there are a few more kind of
variations of Fantasia one is to
recreate Fox odors so get a fox odor
we'll spread that in Japan people smell
it and think oh Fox is around this is a
bad Omen but again what what does a fox
smell like do people really know and so
Salinger scraps all that and he decides
instead we're going to capture live
foxes we're going to paint them with
glowing radioactive paint and we're
going to release them in Japan that way
the Japanese are going to see them and
know this really is a glowing Fox it
must be a kitsuni and it must be a bad
Omen we must be about to lose this war
we might as well give up now
so foxes are captured they're painted
with radioactive paint from the U.S
radiant iridium Corporation
um actually before they are just to see
if paint adheres to fur animal fur they
go the OSS some Personnel go to the
Bronx Zoo and they paint a raccoon and
they let it kind of do raccoon stuff
yeah
for a for a few days these raccoons are
just kind of glowing they're kept away
from from public cancer and glowing yeah
probably but the paint actually stays on
so hey this is one point for operation
Fantasia maybe it works the the next
experiment with this
is to take a few foxes to Rock Creek
Park in Maryland right by DC and release
these glowing foxes the idea is that if
we can see if it scares Americans well
it's definitely going to scare the
Japanese so if the Americans are spooked
out by this the Japanese are going to be
even more spooked out so let's release
these foxes and see how Americans
respond to them so these foxes are
released in Rock Creek Park they're
glowing at night walking through the
trails and there's a newspaper report
later that says the passers-by were
terrified and had the screaming Genies
when they saw these foxes these ghostly
apparitions so hey point two for
operation Fantasia The Americans really
are scared of this thing so there's
another experiment with operation
Fantasia
can foxes swim that's what needs to be
answered because in order to get these
foxes to Japan it's not like you can
just drop them out of a plane or
something you're gonna have to take a
boat drop them in the ocean and let them
swim to shore but can foxes swim this is
the question and so as part of this
operation Fantasia several foxes are
captured they're taken into the middle
of the Chesapeake Bay and they're thrown
overboard and it turns out the foxes
actually did swim to shore so foxes do
swim the problem is that that by the
time they got to shore all the paint had
washed off so it was kind of a bust like
what's the point the paint washes off
that was the whole point of the
operation in the first place so that
didn't really go anywhere but then
Salinger this is what I discovered in
the archives something that I've never
seen anyone else talk about I discovered
this document that talks about how he
wants to carry this even further
he said he had heard when he was in
Japan
uh one of these ideas about kitsuni that
involved a skull it was said that
apparently a fox with a skull on it was
the worst Omen of all this is a really
bad Omen so his idea to capitalize on
this is to Taxidermy a fox to paint it
in glowing paint to take a human skull
and put it on the Fox as if it's you
know its own skull and then he wanted to
have a mechanical a mechanism that could
raise and lower this the jaw of this
skull and then he would blast audio to
the Japanese as if this skull was
talking saying you need to give up the
war it's worth you know just put down
your arms and then he would attach this
fox with a skull and audio to a balloon
and fly it over Japan so it would look
like there was this flowing glowing
stuff Fox talking with a human skull out
of it apparently this is going to win
the war so that's that's his idea so
America tried to
conduct spiritual warfare
on Japan to try and make them think that
the Japanese gods were mad at them with
a glowing Fox that had a human skull on
the top of it yes correct right there
there are a couple other I mean there
are a couple other similar things that
are trying to be done against Japan one
idea that the Army Air Force has is to
drop bombs into Japanese volcanoes that
are dormant and try to get them to
become active and if the volcanoes start
kind of looking like they're active
maybe the Japanese will think that the
gods are mad and then this is an
indication that we shouldn't be in this
war in the first place
[__] yeah that's what I want I want some
let's do that let's anger the Japanese
Gods I think
oh man I mean
there is something about the Advent of
technology that has taken away all of
this beautiful sort of wistful
creativity everything's everything's
what far too logical and rational now uh
one of the other ones that you go
through bat bombs we've spoken about rat
bombs but bat bombs as well strapping a
bomb to a bat I'm gonna guess
uh that is pretty close yeah it's pretty
close so they're yeah they're rat bombs
cat bombs bat bombs if you want any
variation of an at-bomb this book has
got it for you
but the bat bomb idea this is the
brainchild of a guy named
um uh uh little Adams little Adams is a
dentist he's not even involved in the
OSS or anything he's a dentist from
Pennsylvania he goes on a vacation to
Carlsbad Caverns in New Mexico and of
course this is home to a colony of
millions of Mexican free-tailed bats
after he goes on that vacation he hears
about the Japanese attack on Pearl
Harbor and he's a patriotic American and
he wants to try to think of what can I
do to help us win this war that we're
now involved in and he had just been to
Carlsbad and he thinks of this bat bomb
idea what if we strap incendiary devices
to bats and we fly them to Japan and we
release them
these bats will kind of be like
heat-seeking missiles they will
naturally Roost in warehouses and you
know in buildings and they'll explode
after a time delay and these incendiary
devices will catch these buildings on
fire so instead of flying over Japan and
dropping bombs which might not even hit
the target let's release these bats and
the bats are naturally going to go to
these houses and Roost in them and blow
up and start these fires that's the idea
little atoms had one thing really going
for him he was a friend of Eleanor
Roosevelt the first lady of the United
States he gave this proposal to Eleanor
Roosevelt she gave it to her husband the
president of the United States in turn
he gives it to none other than William
Donovan the head of the OSS and attached
to the proposal Franklin Roosevelt
writes this man is not a nut so like you
know this this idea has got something
going for it Donovan he gives it to the
one branch of the OSS capable of
actually studying this the r d Branch so
that's how it gets to the r d branch
Stanley leveled the head of this Branch
hires a man named Louis Pfizer to
develop the incendiary devices that
they're going to attach to these bats
Lewis Pfizer is fairly famous at the
time because he was the inventor of
Napalm this is kind of a jellied
gasoline that if it catches you know if
it sticks to anything and it'll burn at
a really hot temperature it can start
fires really easily actually he had
invented this while he was at Harvard as
he's a chemist and so his first Napalm
bomb tests had occurred on the Harvard
soccer fields so he had he had literally
detonated Napalm bombs on just on the
soccer fields at Harvard he actually got
in trouble for this not so much for the
bombs but because he was hogging the
soccer field and they needed it for
drill instruction so he was told to find
somewhere else but anyway Stanley level
hires Lewis uh yeah Louis Pfizer to
create the Napalm bombs for these bats
really small
there are Personnel who go to different
caves literally swing around Nets and
they capture bats for for the tests that
they're going to do so for one of the
first tests they're not using live kind
of uh incendiaries instead they just
have a kind of a dummy they attach it to
the bats they cool the bats down because
the idea is that we'll put them in an
artificial hibernation state so we can
get them on the plane we'll fly them up
we'll drop them they'll wake up and then
you know they'll fly away and we'll see
how they if they're able to actually fly
with this stuff on the problem is that
when they flew these bats up they had
cooled them down too much so by the time
they dropped them they didn't wake up
and they just kind of crashed into the
wall
so so that was one experiment with this
bat bomb
another experiment they tried with
actual live incendiaries Lewis Pfizer
wanted to test the official package to
make sure it actually worked without a
live incendiaries they cooled down the
bats the problem was that they did
didn't cool him down enough this time
the bats woke up prematurely and they
flew around before they could be stopped
and they actually burned down a control
tower in a Barracks that was nearby so
in a kind of ironic sense the bat bombs
actually seem to work because they did
Roost in these buildings and blow them
up but you know it was never deployed
against the Japanese
Jesus honestly I think that you know
there's an argument to be made that the
atomic bomb wasn't needed we just needed
to have whatever a million bats send
them down into Japan everything would
have been fine what I think is one of
the funniest kind of parts of the book
is that little Adams the guy who
conceived first of this bat bomb idea he
was talking to a lot of different
Generals in the military to try to get
funding because he really wanted to
pursue this idea and make sure the OSS
was kind of carrying it out so he was
talking to generals he comes back and
starts talking to some members of the
OSS really dejected and upset because
the generals didn't want to give him
that much money and little Adam says
yeah there's apparently this other
project in New Mexico and they're kind
of messing around with these atoms why
should we be messing around with atoms
when we have a sure thing let the bat
bomb here
oh man okay so in your opinion given the
fact that you are currently the world
living Authority on the dirty tricks
Department what was the most successful
contrib Fusion or the most pivotal
mission that they were a part of I I
think the most useful contribution is
probably those other two branches the
documents division in the camouflage
division because this enabled agents to
go undercover in Europe especially and
to train resistance forces into gather
intelligence which is actually useful
for making decisions I think that's
probably the most useful thing the most
useful kind of weapon that was invented
it's either that silence 22 that was
actually being used up even through the
Vietnam War in in some places
within different military branches
another one of the useful Technologies
weapons that's developed by this r d
branch is involves derailing trains we
already talked about black Joe that you
could throw in a boiler there were
several other things like that and
derailing trains was especially
effective because not only could you
destroy the train and all the material
on it you could you could derail it but
if you did it strategically you could
really mess things up so one invention
was called the mole and it was a light
sensitive explosive explosive the idea
being it can detect a sudden shift from
light to dark and so if you have a
saboteur that attaches this to a train
and kind of sets it then the light
sensitive mole when whenever the train
enters a tunnel it'll notice that light
to dark and it'll detonate and they'll
derail the train not only derailing the
train but plugging up that valuable
tunnel and preventing any other trains
from getting through so that's a really
useful device one other of the most
useful full devices you kind of
mentioned earlier is probably the Limpet
the OSS and the British soe are kind of
working on this together and sharing
ideas but the limit is this explosive
device that a saboteur could attach to
the bottom of a ship set a time pencil
that would a time delay and then paddle
away establish an alibi somewhere else
and then after a while this Limpet will
explode putting a hole in the ship and
causing it to sink those were used on
many ships during World War II do you
know what the original trigger was that
they used on the very first version of
the Olympic mine they needed something
that would dissolve uh consistently and
was always in a reliable size
I'm not sure it was an unasseed bowl a
sweet like a little candy we would have
called it a candy
um so they're talking about it this is
in uh Churchill's Ministry even
gentleman the Warfare and they're
talking about the fact that they need to
protect it from any moisture because if
it gets a tiny little bit wet during
Transit that means that the timer once
it gets into the ocean is actually going
to be however much shorter I think it's
about the for those that are interested
I think it's around about 45 minutes 30
to 45 minutes is the amount of time an
anise ball takes to dissolve in in the
ocean
um so they're talking about the fact
that they couldn't tell anybody what
they were doing and they had to go
around the local Village buying every
pack of condoms that they could so that
they could individually wrap these
aniseed balls in condoms so that it was
protected from water and the guy that
wrote the book says um it is unclear
whether nine months later there was an
increase in the fertility rate of this
small village because there was no
access to condoms for a couple of weeks
um the the soe must have had a thing
with condoms because there's another
brief thing I mentioned in the book
about how they developed this itching
powder from like the seed part of this
one plant and they would sprinkle it in
condoms that were destined for German
soldiers no way and there were
apparently reports there are apparently
reports of a submarine crew who kind of
came back and they noticed an uptick in
you know hospital visits or whatever so
apparently that was when I did itching
powder dude that is so funny so um we
spoke earlier on about the fact that the
atomic bomb is kind of happening it's
being developed it's not exactly
rivalrous with the with the bat bomb was
the OSS involved in stopping any of the
Germans or keeping tabs on what the
Germans were doing I know that there was
heavy water plants that obviously it was
the Dam Busters there was a bunch of
other operations that tried to really
slow down what the Allies thought was
uh
Nazi development of some sort of atomic
weapon
absolutely the most famous well I'll
start with uh I'll kind of build up to
that there was
pretty much any physicist in the United
States knew that if the Germans were
going to have an atomic bomb program the
person who is going to lead it was
Werner Heisenberg this is one of the
most famous distinguished physicists in
the world at the time he had stayed in
Germany at the outbreak of the war
unlike many of his colleagues who either
came to the United States and would work
on the Manhattan Project or go somewhere
else he stayed in Germany and pretty
much everyone knew if anyone is leading
a German atomic bomb project it is
Werner Heisenberg
so the OSS has a few ways they want to
deal with Werner Heisenberg the idea
being if you kind of cut off the head of
the snake the program is going to
flounder so if you can just if you can
either kidnap or even maybe kill Werner
Heisenberg you could prevent the Germans
from potentially acquiring an atomic
bomb one of the first people who is
assigned to work on this and figure out
what to do with Werner Heisenberg is a
guy named Carl eifler Carl eifler was
head of what's called Detachment 101 in
Burma this is a group of OSS Personnel
that was sent to kind of the Burma India
China area their their mission is to
destroy a Japanese Air Base where the
Japanese are launching planes from he
gets recalled to the United States he
has kind of he got
he was on a mission he fell overboard
into the ocean and he was dashed upon
the rocks and he had like head damage so
he he was a little all over the place
but he got recalled to the United States
but after that he gets assigned
to kidnap Warner Heisenberg to think of
a plan to figure out how to capture
Warner Heisenberg and to smuggle him
into Switzerland and they're going to
Rendezvous with a plane or even a
submarine that will carry him somewhere
else so he gets assigned to this he
ultimately gets called off of that
because he was he was like William
Donovan in the sense that he was so
gung-ho he was rambunctious and wild and
never followed orders and did things his
way and because of that he wasn't really
fit for this operation because it was
going to be a very delicate Affair but
he's the opposite of delicate he's
someone who would just say whatever and
do whatever he wanted so they needed
someone who was a little bit more
Discerning and Technical and skilled so
instead of Carl eifler he's pulled off
the OSS assigns a baseball player named
Mo Berg to assassinate Warner Heisenberg
moberg was a catcher for several
different major league baseball teams
like the the Red Sox you know he was a
catcher he what made him valuable to the
OSS is that he spoke many languages so
he was kind of a polyglot he spoke
several languages that he had studied in
school or grown up with and so that's
very valuable to the OSS because
especially as say an agent he can pass
as someone else because he can speak the
language with the dialect and the
emphasis and accent and whatever
he gets assigned to assassinate Warner
Heisenberg he's told that Warner
Heisenberg is scheduled to give a talk
in Switzerland on a specific date at the
specific University so moberg goes over
there
and he's told to sit in the lecture and
if Warner Heisenberg says anything that
indicates that he might be working on an
atomic bomb anything about fission or
you know uh chain reactions he's
supposed to pull out a gun and shoot
Werner Heisenberg right there in the
lecture hall so moberg goes to this
lecture he sits down he's got a cyanide
yeah for sure armed with a gun he's got
a cyanide pill in his pocket the idea
being after the assassination he's going
to kill himself so he listens to the
lecture and his notes from the lecture
still exist you know he says I'm sitting
you know in the third row and Warner
Heisenberg is looking at me a lot
because he thinks I'm taking notes and
you know he thinks I'm really interested
in what he's talking about and all this
stuff so his notes are you know survive
Mo Berg doesn't get the sense that the
topic it has anything to do with an
atomic bomb so he decides not to take
the risk and assassinate Warner
Heisenberg right there
a few days later moberg gets invited to
a dinner with some physicists in
Switzerland
who is there Werner Heisenberg so
they're talking about the war and all
kinds of stuff Warner Heisenberg decides
that he has to leave early he's got to
go do something but Mo bird takes the
opportunity to leave early too so that
he can leave with Warner Heisenberg and
they can walk together for a while
giving Mo Berg an opportunity to
interrogate Warner Heisenberg of course
his cover story is that he's you know
this Swiss physics student so he's
talking to Werner Heisenberg in Swiss
accented German because Heisenberg
speaks German so he's asking him
questions kind of leading questions are
you working on anything you know what's
the state of nuclear physics and he
still doesn't get the impression that
Heisenberg is really doing anything with
the German atomic bomb so he decides not
to kill him but those were kind of the
OSS attempts to assassinate Heisenberg
and thus deny Germany his brain to build
the atomic bomb
and this guy this catcher for the Red
Sox was prepared to take his own life as
well that was the level advice that he
was ready to do
yes so um not not only that with him but
with Carl eifler too Carl eifler asks
William Donovan and the other uh kind of
high-ranking OSS Personnel when he's
launching this kidnapping Mission
originally that it doesn't even go
through but he asked them what am I
supposed to do if I'm captured obviously
I'll kidnap Heisenberg or maybe even
kill him but I'm gonna be captured
afterwards people are gonna think I just
murdered this guy what do I do and they
said we will deny you in other words
we're not going to acknowledge that
you're even part of our organization
that's you'll just have to deal with it
and so he he accepts and goes on but it
never went through absolutely ruthless
so what about we mentioned it earlier on
and I think you're right you are right
it's interesting uh levels
uh ethical trajectory from the beginning
of the war until the end of it about
what he felt was appropriate about the
kind of force
um getting into chemical warfare what
was uh developed used
um what sort of tactics and then what
kind of personal reflection and
challenges did level face with that you
are right because this like I said is
one of the major arcs I'm following in
this book is Stanley level going from
someone who is reluctant to even create
kind of deadly weapons like a silence
pistol to someone by the end of the war
he is advocating for the use of weapons
of mass destruction not only the atomic
bomb but also chemical agents biological
agents so in the r d Branch he's
involved with experimenting with some of
these agents
um
the United States had developed a an
installation in Maryland called Fort
Dedrick or Camp Dedrick at that time it
was kind of the biological warfare
installation where mass production of
Anthrax and all kinds of diseases were
created the United States or Franklin
Roosevelt in particular had said that he
has a no first use policy so the United
States is not going to use these weapons
first but we're going to create them as
a deterrent Force so if somebody uses
them we have them to retaliate and just
by having them we can deter others from
using them that's his idea Stanley level
disagrees with this by the end of the
war he comes to think that
any way that you can end the war as soon
as possible is the ethical thing to do
so not just something we should do but
this is the ethical thing to do
especially regarding biological warfare
he says look at the differences here you
can stab someone in the stomach with a
Bayonet and it's going to get infected
and they're going to die from an
infection or you can infect them with
Anthrax or something through the through
a biological bomb and they'll get an
infection and die at least with the
second option we spare them the bayonet
and at least we don't have to stab them
first before they get this infection he
comes to see chemical warfare especially
as an ethical alternative to
Conventional Warfare with chemical
warfare he starts developing the idea
that perhaps you can especially in the
Pacific Theater in these islands in
Japan like Iwo Jima
there are these Japanese soldiers
stationed on these islands instead of
sending American forces to storm the
island that's going to lead to tens of
thousands of casualties why don't we
just shell the island with chemical
weapons these don't even necessarily
have to kill the Japanese just like
paralyze them or you know something and
then we go on the island and prevent
those casualties from happening so
Stanley level becomes in favor of using
those because he sees it as the ethical
alternative
doesn't he have a son somewhere as well
isn't there a little bit of perverse
incentive here yes this is a really
important point because as the end of
the war is coming to a close
Stanley level's son is on a ship Midway
across the Pacific waiting to engage in
an invasion of Japan and so the sooner
the war ends the sooner that Stanley
level son gets to come back home
um so he he's of course thinking
personally about his son too but in
general he's also thinking if we don't
use these weapons to end the war as soon
as possible that's just going to lead to
a lot more casualties we might as well
end the war now of course one of the I
mean there are several kind of ways to
debate with what Stanley level is
arguing here what about the the
precedent that it sets for future Wars
what about the potential that this could
spread to civilian populations at least
if you you know storm an island you it's
a little bit targeted if you just drop
biological or chemical weapons somewhere
it's not really targeted it could spread
to anyone so that there are a lot of uh
there are a lot of objections that you
could raise to what Stanley level is
saying and when Stanley level's grandson
after the war
years later kind of raises some of these
objections especially to the atomic bomb
Stanley level was in favor of using it
his grandson wasn't Stanley level
basically said we're an inventive people
we'll figure it out so we'll figure out
how to deal with this stuff we just need
to end the war we just needed to end the
war when we could have were there many
chemical weapons used during World War
II I remember hearing about mustard gas
and stuff like that during World War one
but I don't remember reading or hearing
about many chemical weapons in World War
II at all
yeah um I'm not I'm not too familiar and
certainly not as much as World War one I
have heard reports that you know the
Germans might have used it on this one
particular battle and some you know
somewhere so there are reports that that
happened but I'm I don't actually know
if they they were yeah interesting it
just seems to me especially as Hitler
got more and more desperate when he was
fighting war on two different fronts
when it we're really starting to
Scrabble Stalingrad etc etc
he was prepared to do pretty much
anything it seems surprising to me that
there would be some ethic that he was
unprepared to break
in service of him I mean he killed
himself you know and encouraged the
people around him to do it too
Stanley level's explanation for this was
that if the Germans used especially
chemical weapons then they knew that the
the Allies were going to respond in kind
and the way that Stanley level explains
this is that the German military was
much more dependent on horses especially
and so you know he he says kind of after
the war he's kind of thinking about this
why didn't the Germans just use chemical
weapons at Normandy and kind of Stop The
Invasion and you know he apparently he
hears from someone but I don't know how
true this is that well the Germans knew
that if they did that then the Allies
were going to use these chemical weapons
which would ruin their basically way of
transporting material which was these
horses they were so dependent on so that
could be one explanation
um I'm not really confident in lovell's
recollection of that particular incident
so I don't know if that's the case but
that's how he rationalized it how does
libel's career finish what's his legacy
level becomes a businessman after World
War II he starts a chemical company they
invent all kinds of stuff like different
patents on shoes and filters and all
kinds of stuff
his most lasting Legacy though really
involves his
truth drug experiments that we talked
about
during the Cold War Sydney Gottlieb that
chemist who ran MK Ultra was trying to
figure out what kinds of experiments he
would do to determine whether truth
drugs are possible or mind control are
possible and he didn't really know where
to start to get inspiration for that he
started looking at old records the
records that he pulled from the archives
Stanley levels records from the OSS and
so there's this pretty direct connection
between Stanley level not intentionally
but influencing directly Sydney Gottlieb
in the creation of this MK Ultra and
trajectory of this MK Ultra program to
the point where the person that Sydney
Gottlieb and the CIA who he hired to
perform these truth drug experiments was
none other than George White that same
guy that Stanley level had hired to
perform truth drug experiments Sydney
Gottlieb had seen White's kind of
reports in the World War II files and
figured I need someone to perform truth
drug experiments I'll just use that same
guy
this was really exciting to me there are
a lot more connections between Stanley
level and Sydney godlib and when I was
writing this I knew that there there was
some connection there you know they're
they're their careers were so similar
during World War II in the OSS Stanley
level was involved in creating deadly
weapons and disguises and documents and
Truth drugs and experiments and all
kinds of stuff Sydney Gottlieb is
involved in that exact same stuff almost
to an item for the CIA and the Cold War
so I had these two chemists and I I
wanted to play them off each other
somehow they're different careers at
these different times and how they're so
similar so I was in the archives and I
found these depositions that Sydney
Gottlieb had to give in the 1980s he was
being sued by victims of the CIA and
required to give these depositions
and in the archives you can't read
everything because you want to get as
much material while you're there as
possible so I would take a deposition I
would take a picture of each page but I
wouldn't really read the pages because I
can read those later when I'm in the
archives I'm just Gathering material but
I was really excited because I had been
looking so long for this connection
between level and Gottlieb and as always
flipping through these Pages taking
picture I looked at one of the
depositions and I saw the name Stanley
level and so I knew somewhere in there
Sydney got leave is talking about
Stanley level and how they're connected
somehow and so if you want to know what
that is in more detail you got to read
the book
John Lyle ladies and gentlemen John I
absolutely love this this kind of
um very unique investigation into
history uh the inventiveness of everyone
that you found I think is fascinating
dirty drinks department will be linked
in the show notes below if people want
to go and get that and if they want to
keep up to date with the other stuff
that you do where should they go yeah
the best place is probably Twitter just
at John Lyle l-i-s-l-e is my last name
and if you're kind of interested in this
story not only do I post stuff about my
book and whatever but a lot of times
most of what I post is just adventures
in the archives if I find a cool photo
or description or something in the
archive I post it to Twitter so if
you're interested in seeing what a
historian does that's probably a good
place to get a some exp you know to see
what it's like so if you want to follow
me on Twitter you can expect some of
that stuff John I didn't think that you
could make history being a historian
cool but you've managed to do it
congratulations thank you thank you I
appreciate it what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace